why luxury brands are entering the nft
market
luxury brands are continuing to launch
non-fungible tokens despite the bear
Market one reason high-end brands are
embracing nfts is because they desire
exclusivity and see this as a perfect
opportunity to engage with tech savvy
customers
so it comes as no surprise that fashion
brands such as Dolce Gabbana Burberry
Prada and Gucci have all launched nfts
the highest selling fashion nft is a
Dolce gabbana's Doge Crown which patched
423.5 each or roughly 1.3 million
dollars in September 2021 but there are
some issues around nfts for example
traceability and scams continue to be a
challenge despite the digital
Collectibles being tracked and verified
on the blockchain nft trading volumes
are down 97 from a record high in
January 2022 they slid to just 466
million dollars in September from 17
billion dollars at the start of 2022
despite this luxury Brands remain
undeterred and continue to launch as the
rich continued to get richer the luxury
Market remains desirable and Brands will
continue to jump on the nft bandwagon
seeing it as a perfect opportunity to
build a new virtual relationship with
our customers